en el espejo el reflejo de una niña a
gusto con sí mismo
juanita tiene siete años en su
habitación hay patines flores y una casa
de muñecas fue asignada como un niño al
nacer pero siempre se sintió una niña
[Música]
pero son por todas estas son las botas
de invierno de broma
al principio confundida su madre mariana
siguió los consejos de una psicóloga
para apoyar a su hija en su transición
de género hemos hecho muñecas con pene
porque no hay acá en argentina no hay
una psicóloga nos pusimos de acuerdo
para poder utilizar con otras infancias
estamos a 300 kilómetros de la capital
buenos aires- en azul ciudad
conservadora de 70 mil habitantes en
este lugar no fue fácil conseguir que
juanita aceptara su identidad
transgénero tenemos varias situaciones
por ejemplo ir a un hospital y que la
llamarán por su nombre de varón y ella
decir solo me llamo de esa manera
entonces angustiarse entonces decidimos
ver cómo podíamos hacer para cambiar el
documento para iniciar el procedimiento
la familia de la pequeña entró en
contacto con un abogado de derechos
humanos facundo atxaga tomó a cargo el
proceso en 2020 en aquel momento juanita
tenía cinco años yo traté de poder
abordarla si se percibía esta mujer sin
que a ella le resultara de invasivo este
pedirle que se dibujara a sí misma se le
observa con pelo largo y vestido cuando
el abogado le pidió que escribiera su
nombre la pequeña escogió juanita el
procedimiento para cambiar sus
documentos de identidad tomó menos de un
mes en argentina desde el 2012 la ley de
identidad de género permite escoger el
género y estado civil con una simple
petición y sin límite de edad el país
sudamericano fue el primero en el mundo
en implementar esta medida incluso hoy
sigue estando entre los más avanzados a
nivel internacional no es necesario un
informe psicológico psiquiátrico porque
la ley lo que hace es
despatologizar al transgénero
no se considera ningún tipo de
enfermedad mental ni se requiere ningún
cambio físico visible en el cuerpo desde
la aprobación de esta ley hace una
década más de 9000 personas han
solicitado oficialmente el cambio de su
identidad de género
marcela romero fue una de las coautoras
de esta innovadora ley diez años más
tarde ella se manifiesta en las calles
para exigir a los legisladores ir más
lejos pelota argentino la democracia y
una hora dorada con la población tras lo
derecho a trotar y eso dentro se llama
la ley integral trazó una ley que va a
beneficiar a toda la población para no
una ley global que debe ser debatida en
el congreso y tiene el objetivo de
garantizar la inclusión social de esta
población ya que en este país pionero en
derechos para la población transgénero
el 80 por ciento vive entre caridad y la
expectativa de vida de una mujer trans
en argentina de 35 a 40 años
principalmente por la exclusión social
en la cual vivimos y cuando yo fuera del
sistema de falta de atención en los
hospitales vivienda trabajo y beneficios
con modales de otra persona una fuerte
discriminación que se traduce en muchas
ocasiones en crímenes de odio en 2020
129 personas trans fueron víctimas de
estos crímenes con 32 años fiorella ha
enfrentado casi toda su vida está bien y
me encontré en situación de calle en
situación de prostitución no pude
terminar mi secundario acceder al
trabajo en lo personal me afecta
muchísimo la historia de fiorella no es
un caso aislado en argentina menos de
una cuarta parte de personas trans
terminan sus estudios secundarios el 95%
tienen un empleo precario o están
desempleadas y una gran mayoría obtiene
su sustento del trabajo sexual
consciente de estas dificultades en el
acceso al empleo este grupo financiero
creó en 2018 una red de empresas
bautizada pride connection ésta promueve
medidas más inclusivas hacia las
personas lgtb más para integrarlas mejor
en el mundo laboral por ejemplo cuando
una entrevista tiene el uno puede hacer
abiertamente la pregunta al candidato
bueno con qué pronombre quieres que yo
acceda a la entrevista con voz cosas que
probablemente en el pasado no se veía
tan tan claramente sebastián es uno de
los dos empleados trans de jeep y morgan
fue contratado a finales de 2020 este
ejecutivo supervisa a una veintena de
personas con su empleo espera cambiar
las mentalidades en la sociedad no está
pensado que una persona trans esté en
este lugar entonces el 8 el solo hecho
de estar ocupando un puesto de liderazgo
en una empresa multinacional
es un acto revolucionario de algún modo
no en 2021 el gobierno se propuso una
cuota del 1 por ciento para las personas
transgénero en la administración pública
la ley también fomenta la contratación
en el sector privado mediante
deducciones fiscales una medida que ha
permitido que argentina se caracteriza
como pionera en derechos para la
comunidad transgénero
[Música]